comparando con los demás países de la
Unión Europea Francia tiene una de las
edades de jubilación más bajas es justa
esta reforma
en la el debate digamos que está puesto
en términos simplistas de si aumenta en
la esperanza de vida tiene que aumentar
la edad de de pensionarse pero pues eso
esconde muchos otros problemas que de
pronto son específicos en el caso de
Francia es que por ejemplo las personas
de cierta edad no trabajan en Francia
tienen un alto nivel de desempleo
entonces hay otros temas que tendría que
abordar la la reforma que no están
digamos en las discusiones
la tasa de pobreza también de las
personas pensionadas que va aumentando
en toda Europa y en Francia no se aborda
como un tema central de la Reforma ahora
los sindicatos han dicho que no
detendrán la huelga hasta que se levante
la reforma qué alternativas tiene el
gobierno
pues ha habido ejemplos en la historia
reciente de Francia y creo que lo
mencionaron antes en el caso de sacos y
el presidente sarcosí de reformas que
simplemente no se pudieron hacer por la
oposición de los sindicatos y realmente
en este caso no solo los sindicatos
tienen una posición muy fuerte sino que
la población francesa en general y
también un apoyo de diferentes partidos
de de izquierda de extrema derecha que
tienen una fuerza importante en el
parlamento Entonces yo creo que el
presidente de maco y su gobierno no
están en una situación muy fácil para
pasar en una reforma impopular a
propósito del tema que mencionaba usted
en el parlamento también opositores como
la líder de derecha Marín lepén han
dicho que harán lo posible para bloquear
esta reforma realmente cuentan con los
recursos para hacerlo
es muy difícil porque pues ya vemos
desde el mes de octubre se ha usado
mucho un artículo de la Constitución
Francesa que permite pasar digamos a la
fuerza las leyes sin tener la mayoría en
el parlamento porque el presidente de
macron tiene esa debilidad que no tiene
mayoría en el parlamento entonces lo que
intentan hacer es convencer a la derecha
que vote a favor de las propuestas de de
y Hasta ahora ha funcionado y en el caso
de esa reforma de las pensiones primero
hablaron con el partido de derecha para
asegurarse de que tengan digamos una
mayoría suficiente para pasar la ley a
pesar de la oposición tanto de la
izquierda como de la extrema derecha